ja ich weiß dass dort nicht wartet und
ja ich will jetzt auch losfahren
wtf bauleute und willkommen zurück bei
einer neuen folge happy meals die letzte
ich bin grad ein bisschen erkältet wenn
man mir das irgendwie anhört ich weiß
nicht wie man sich bei dem wetter
erkälten kann es ist übelst als 35 grad
draußen ich jetzt hier gerade meinem
zimmer schön kalt alles schön schön cool
und ich habe ich mich wohl erkältet
irgendwie an dem ventilator dingsbums
der übrigens mein größter fans der
ventilator der guckt mir immer zu egal
was ich mache ja jedenfalls wollte ich
in dieser folge noch mal ganz kurz über
die gamescom reden alle machen ja jetzt
zurzeit so richtig tolle videos geschaut
wie ich aus dem real life guckt mal
schreibt mich alle an seht mich an wenn
ich auf der gamescom in quatsch so
erhalte ich jetzt nicht so viel von also
wenn man da teilweise youtube lieber
machen da mehrere videos und filmen und
laden täglich 20 videos von der gamescom
horror und alles mögliche naja im halte
ich jetzt nicht so viel von ich wollte
euch nur mal kurz in diesem happy meals
parteien bisschen über die gamescom
quatschen nebenbei spielen einfach
irgendwie sondern so ein level hier mit
vater und sohn das könnt ihr ganz
interessant werden
ok hallo ich das schon das werden wir
solche glasscherben
dann wäre ich jetzt theoretisch wieder
zurückfahren wo ist da dann wieder gehen
die dinge okay gut egal was will denn
dieser ninja da von uns zdf
ok cool das ist eine alte wegmann boal
dachte oha geweckt alter schwede junge
wussten uns hallo
ich blute tut mir leid wenn ich jetzt
zwischendurch vielleicht bisschen husten
muss aber inhalt bisschen krank so
zurück aufs thema gamescom auch sie
mussten erst mal das tor aufmachen war
geweckt cool danke sobek flirt oder
kommen jetzt eine pistole müssen hier
wieder irgendwie weg jetzt kommt
jährigen typ wie woche daten schaffen
moment also gamescom ich muss man hier
wieder ein thema anquatschen wusste ich
gar nicht so oft beim bei der sache
bleiben offen
danke ich bin am sonntag da also da wäre
dieser video day ist da ich habe da
keine karte gekriegt aber den ergibt mit
einer karte also dehner müsste
eigentlich kennen war
jetzt macht stellen offen hier tabu
das war geil dena gibt mir ein video der
karte der den wii 2 oder so und dann bin
ich am sonntag weight ok dann hätte ich
da wohl warten müssen
mdr gibt mit einer video day karte und
dann bin ich am sonntag so von 11 uhr
morgens bis denke ich also neun uhr
abends auf der gamescom läuft dann
vielleicht ein bisschen mit denen rum
also wenn ihr wisst wie der aussieht und
da ich zum verrückten jungen mit ihm
rumlaufen seht die ganz viel scheiß
machen dann bin ich das schiff wenig ab
wo alter wie ich dieses spiel vermisst
dabei naja jedenfalls ich werde kein
video machen wo ich mich zeigt aber ich
werde auf der gamescom filmen und das
video dann natürlich dann mit musik und
alle möglichen extras dann hochladen
irgendwie paar tage nach der gamescom
und wird auf jeden fall ganz cool denke
ich das video und müsst ihr dann einfach
mein channel weiter verfolgen das
gamescom bietet kommt übrigens auch auf
diesem kanal habe ich mir gedacht da
dass die meisten leute hier natürlich
auch interessiert so gut und jetzt
weight ok
sehr schön so weitergeht sich das gleich
wieder in die welt kommt dann fällt er
weiter habe es jetzt geschafft
bf bf
ok cool 8 40 sekunden komisches level
muss ich sagen spiel mit dead space hd
displays weisen spiel was ich mir holen
wollte also noch mal kurz um das thema
hier gamescom alter macht die türen
offen mir kommt der daddy offen
dank alter was das für ein ding so oder
was das für eine masse bareither oder
labbadia war hilfe bei gebrochen
richtig fahrt einfach nur hier do you
have to play the level stofer get safe
the place to be still here junge ja okay
gut interessantes leather ehrlich gesagt
na ja es geht aber ich bin einfach
natürlich gefahren hab s geschafft also
verlangt jetzt nicht unbedingt meinen
kompletten skill den ich natürlich
besitzt
hallo
ein schönes gebäude lasse mich durch ok
für die happy meals level dies vor ein
paar monaten gab die waren gar nicht so
cool wie die jetzigen also gar nicht so
gut designt so als ich voll geil
verändert eigentlich
oh mein gott da stöhnen leute alter was
ist aus diesem tollen spiel nur geworden
früher war so kinderfreundlich war dass
wir hoch erst mal an schwung nehmen so
komisch naja gamescom noch mal ganz kurz
ich bin sonntag da überall da gibt es
noch ganz gut
hilfe ich hoffe dass ein bisschen
bauchtraining im alter was ist mit
meinem mund los und meinem hals das tut
weh meint ertel tag meint ertel kenne
ich von links hier von ridgeback und
holt space up trends
schönborn meinte limbach
sydney perth cannonball los nein das
sind keine kennen bolz mehr drin
nein nein ich brauche ich brauch bälle
fakt ist so ich dachte explodiert doch
das sind wieder welche okay die sind
wohl doch explodiert ok so erstmal den
einer cranes typen weg also ich bin
sonntag auf der gamescom passt da kommt
er lappens debatten of the shell
verdammt komm wieder zurückkehren wollen
ein [ __ ] das sind wieder keine bälle
mehr drin als erwartet ist das ein
konstruktionsfehler
doch da anderes level teamwork mission
prezi
doch ich hab das ja sehr schön
okay gut los ich mache das von think
tanks ich bin auf dem weg bei allen
alter die stellt sich an - eine spende
über los du schaffst es online online
online ist james das motorrad
losgelassen
ach du scheiße los kommt ibm auf der
brücke hauptsache der schalter ist offen
hallo carolina chapel noch guck mal ich
mach jetzt nicht mehr das muss das wohl
allein machen machen wir nochmal also
shift t und jetzt runter hier so gut das
ging ja schon mal schneller
das war richtig gut wieder c jetzt müsst
ihr die tür hier endlich offen gehen
carolina tut mir leid kein ding jetzt
nutzt teil hier im links
nein ich lasse doch nicht aus es ist ein
scheiß leveling wie kommt stand weiter
übrigens sie könnte glauben die
kommentare schreiben soll ich das lieber
so machen wie jetzt dass ich quasi
werden level dorf ist das desktop mende
oder soll ich die ganze zeit sondern
level weiter probieren weil wir haben
sich ein paar beschwert dass sich
zusteller aufgeben sich beschwert dass
ich zu langsam auf gebe also mir zu viel
zeit lasse und jetzt hab ich gerade
bluescreen ja hallo was hier noch mal
etwas hallo
ja mir geht es gut
hallo die cgm bin ich gar nicht ein
bisschen verwirrt was hier los ist
naja jedenfalls ich würde sagen ich
natürlich immer ganz kurz die seite
vielleicht bringt das ja was okay die
seite habe ich als aktualisiert
altersjahr musik laut wjasna am ich
denke da wollten wir nicht rein wir
gehen jetzt mal in crime city
hauptsache schnell rein dass diese musik
endlich auf einen stil wenn man okay gut
ab excel add on de sell rating space
break shift nitro
a
ok kobler ampel nicht ob ich auf ampeln
achten nitro und jedoch nicht und halo 4
jetzt schließt ich drück nicht mehr in
der taste der fährt einfach ganz von
alleine mache ich liebe das dass dieses
spiel einfach keine bugs hat jetzt von
ganz allein wieder rückwärts ach ist das
schön kombi start nochmal von vorne
vielleicht lag es auch nur im level ja
ich weiß dass du auf mich wartet und ja
ich will jetzt auch losfahren
wtf bricht sich einfach mal sein seine
brust körper beim autofahren
obwohl er einfach nur stand so war ganz
interessant
also das ist doch das erste ja wir haben
das schon mal gemacht er ist können wir
noch mal machen einfach ist das erste
was ich hier gespielt habe
da war ich so ein kack drin weil ich gar
nicht die steuerung und alles wusste mal
schauen ob ich jetzt besser bin okay
okay und scheint nicht und habe mal
lasst mich doch hier hoch und witz so
sehr schön
lasst mich durch lasst mich durch das
nein das ist später the uk coal diotima
okay gut jetzt hier noch unter dem ich
nehmen wir auch gleich mit so hier die
die pranke hoch r kom kom kom tel
das tut mir leid aber so backsteine ist
auch ganz lecker so beim frühstück oder
so schon ganz interessant live action
battle ja das war wirklich actionreich
was mich
okay gut wir müssten es eigentlich
gleich geschafft haben so wie ich das
level in erinnerung habe nämlich genau
hier nach
doch gerade sexy hold up for one second
place
das mache ich jetzt wieder runter
gescrollt ihr das mache ich ein anderes
mal bekommt ein hallo hallo hallo hallo
hallo okay
mit diesem plus beenden wir das jetzt
auch mal wieder wir sind schon wieder
über 15 minuten
ihr könnt mir immer in die kommentare
schreiben
ob ihr schon bei der gamescom watt oder
ob ihr letztes jahr da war oder ob hier
noch hinfahrt oder ob er am sonntag da
seid oder irgendwie sowas halt wie es
euch dieses jahr gefallen weil ich mir
noch nicht so viele videos angesehen
habe ich weiß nur dass assassin's creed
dahin kommen wird fifa und need for
speed und black ops und league of
legends
viel mehr weiß ich gar nicht doch guild
wars 2 habe ich noch gesehen und far cry
oder weist jedoch schon eine menge
aber verglichen damit dass die zwölf
hallen sind ist das schon relativ wenig
wo ich das weiss ich bin auch nicht so
viel da ein spiel anzugucken sondern nur
ein bisschen zu schnell ein paar leute
zu treffen weil zocken tue ich an sich
eigentlich nur um minecraft und fifa und
cod vielleicht manchmal aber mich wird
eure meinung der echt interessieren
warte schon auf der gamescom dieses jahr
und dann würde ich einfach mal sagen mit
diesem tollen bluescreen wir sehen uns
bei der nächsten folge ich würde mich
noch mal freuen und schau